-Former president Donald Trump
will give his first speech
since leaving office
this weekend
at the Conservative
Political Action Conference,
and Republicans are still
rallying around him
as the future
and the leader of the GOP.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
After five years
of doing
everything possible
to hide them,
it was reported today that
Donald Trump was finally forced
to turn over his tax records
to the Manhattan
district attorney this week,
after the Supreme Court denied
his last-ditch attempt
to keep them concealed.
And look,
I'm no prosecutor,
but it can't be that hard
to find a crime
in the tax records of a guy
who claims to be a billionaire
yet paid only $750
in federal income taxes
when he was president.
It wasn't way back
in the '80's,
when he was just a New York
real estate developer
and I'm guessing aspiring
birthday magician.
"Mom, that guy made
my presents disappear."
This was 2017,
when he was the most powerful
and most famous person
in the world.
It was so brazen I'm shocked he
didn't livestream it.
"'Sup, fam,
welcome to my Twitch stream.
Today, we'll be committing
tax fraud.
And make sure to subscribe,
because next week,
we'll be playing
the new online Ocean Master."
And yes, there are plenty
of technically legal ways
that the wealthy
and corporations avoid taxes,
which is a scandal
in itself.
But something tells me
Trump doesn't just limit himself
to the legal stuff.
I'm guessing
he commits crimes
the way the rest of us
order apps for the table.
"Let's just get -- should
we just get one of everything?"
So, a criminal investigation
in Manhattan is intensifying,
not to mention an investigation
in Georgia of his attempts
to steal the election there.
Plus, there are, like,
I don't know,
30 other investigations,
last I checked.
Oh, and also, there was
that whole insurrection thing.
And yet,
he's still scheduled
to give his first
post-presidency speech
to the Conservative Political
Action Conference on Sunday --
a move that has most
Republicans thrilled,
but also caused a few
awkward moments in the party,
as evidenced by
the public split yesterday
between House GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy
and Congresswoman
Liz Cheney,
who voted
to impeach Trump.
-Yes. He should.
-On that high note...
[ Laughter ]
-[ Fake laughs ]
Very funny.
The GOP responds to divisions
over the future of their party
like an uncle who farts
at Thanksgiving dinner.
"Oh. And with that, I will
retire to the family room."
It was rare to see that kind
of disunity on public display
because,
during his presidency,
Trump commanded
near-universal loyalty
within the Republican party,
despite his abysmal record
of failure
on both policy and politics.
Remember, he never cracked
50% approval once,
he was impeached twice,
he lost the popular vote twice,
he lost the House
by the highest margin
since Watergate,
and lost the Senate in January
when Democrats
won two Senate seats.
In what was once a reliably
red state, Georgia,
sticking with Trump
is like putting Ringo
in charge
of the Beatles.
[As Ringo] "Okay. what about
more songs where I sing?
Also, a no autograph policy.
Peace and love."
[Normal voice]
Why on earth would you want
to stick with a guy
who's basically
single-handedly responsible
for your political
annihilation?
It reminds me of
my weekly bowling team.
We would all hit at least 200
every week, except for Dale,
who would always chuck the ball
across two lanes
because he had gravy all over
his hands from the disco fries.
And every week,
I'd tell my teammates,
"Let's cut Dale loose."
And they'd say, "We can't
because he bankrolls the team
with the million dollar
settlement he won from the local
Dairy Queen when he spilled
the blizzard in his lap
and his dog
got frostbite."
Anyway, the point is,
Republicans stuck by Trump
no matter how bad he was
for the party
because they agreed
with him.
They were engaged
in the same project,
and wanted
the same things.
With a few exceptions,
they were all Trump.
I mean, Lindsey Graham
literally wore the same clothes
when they went golfing,
like a Chihuahua
whose owner makes them wear
matching outfits.
This looks like one of those
pictures of Manute Bol
and Muggsy Bogues when they both
played for the Bullets.
It was called "The Bullets"
before they changed it
to "The Wizards."
It took an armed insurrection
stoked by the president,
fueled by insane lies
about election fraud,
to finally
put some distance
between a few Republicans
and Trump.
Even Graham,
as you might recall,
briefly suggested that
he might finally be ready
to separate himself
from Trump.
-Trump and I, look, we've had
a hell of a journey.
I hate it
to end this way.
Oh, my God,
I hate it.
From my point of view, he's been
a consequential president.
But today,
first thing you'll see,
all I can say is
count me out.
Enough is enough.
-I believe he was reciting
a monologue
from the Tennessee Williams play
"A Streetcar Named De-Liar."
You can stay for the rest
of the "Closer Look,"
but it's all downhill
from there.
What's that?
You want me to do a scene
from "Streetcar named De-Liar"?
I couldn't. Okay.
[Southern accent] We've had a
long journey, Trump and I,
from the salt marshes of
Charlton, to the river boats
of Mississippi,
to the Sparkleberry swamp.
Meemaw says he's just a figment
of my imagination,
but to me,
he was real --
as real as a glass of peach tea
on a warm Chattanooga knight.
God, I hate it to end this way,
but sometimes life comes up
and bites you, like an
Appalachian salamander
on a meth bender.
[Normal voice]
And scene.
Well, it won't surprise you
to learn that Graham
almost immediately
did a 180.
He probably thought that,
by calling out
Trump's bad behavior one time,
you get to co-host a podcast
with Obama
and Springsteen.
[As Graham]
"Fellas, I'm looking at my
Spotify, and I cannot believe
I am finding out like this.
Well, count me out."
[As Obama] "You can't be out
when you were never in."
[As Springsteen]
"Yeah, Linds..."
Ooh.
[Normal voice] I tried to get
two rock 'n' rollers.
And I nailed the Ringo.
That's it.
You always said, "Only one
rock 'n' roller a show."
[As Springsteen]
"Yeah, Linds."
[Normal voice]
That was a little better.
[As Springsteen]
"You're out, Linds" --
[ Laughs ]
[Normal voice] Graham's been
all over cable news,
proclaiming Trump the face
of the Republican party
even after the insurrection
and the mass death
and misery
his presidency produced.
Over the weekend, Graham flew to
Trump's Mar-a-Lago resort
to spend time golfing
and dining with Trump.
He has spoken to
the former president
nearly daily since January 6th,
more frequently than
any of his Republican colleagues
in the Senate.
They talk almost daily?
I don't even speak to my own
family on a daily basis.
I tried to Zoom
with my dad last week,
but he wouldn't stop
complaining about
how much he hates
the Sea Captain.
Still.
Let it go, Dad.
He hasn't been on the show
for months.
Last I heard, his crew threw him
overboard for hoarding limes.
-It was Margarita Monday.
-Anything else, Dad.
-Samberg texted,
and wanted me to tell you
that Frisbee sucks.
-Dude, she's here today.
-[ Laughs ]
My bad.
-I told you to leave after the
"Streetcar Named De-Liar" jokes.
If you're still here,
that's on you.
Quiet, Frisbee.
Don't worry. She's not here.
we pre-tape that.
Anyway, the point is, even after
a violent insurrection
to overthrow the government,
the GOP has essentially
pledged its unwavering loyalty
to Trump.
And now, he's set to make
his first political speech
since leaving office
this week at CPAC --
not to be confused
with CPAP,
which is what Melania
wears at night
so Trump won't try
to kiss her.
[As Trump]
"Yeah, it's really sad.
It has something to do
with her airways.
It's a medical condition.
Melania,
what's it called?
Mel?
What's your sleep
thing called?
I want to say Sleep Applejack,
but that's definitely wrong.
Mel?
Is it Sleep Applebee's?
She's sleeping bad
in the neighborhood.
Did you hear that, Mel?
I did a spin
on the Applebee's --
she probably can't hear me
over the machine."
[Normal voice]
And in advance of the speech,
Graham has been all over
cable news,
talking up Trump as the leader
and the future of the party.
-Trump's gonna give a speech
Sunday that's gonna be
very policy-centric.
Every Republican
should rally around it.
I think it will help us
with Independents.
And I've never felt better
about President Trump's
leading the party
than I do right now.
-First of all, you really expect
us to believe his speech
is gonna be policy-centric?
His speeches
weren't even policy-centric
when he was president.
I bet I can predict
what it'll be.
He'll spend a half an hour
whining about getting canceled,
zing Cheney a few times.
At some point,
he'll say a curse word,
and the crowd will go nuts
like a bunch of fifth graders
when the music teacher says
the word "pianist" too fast.
And then,
he'll mention The Squad,
and everybody'll boo.
The whole thing is basically
"Rocky Horror Picture Show"
for wingnuts.
By the way, at the same time
that he's openly cheerleading
a former president who tried
to overturn an election,
incited a violent
insurrection,
and routinely called for his
political enemies to be jailed,
Graham is also calling
President Biden's
COVID relief package
"divisive,"
despite the fact that it is
overwhelmingly popular in polls.
Just yesterday, a poll found
that 76% of voters,
including 60% of Republicans,
support the bill.
Do you know how rare
that kind of consensus is?
You can't even get 76% of voters
to agree to vote.
And yet, Graham had this
to say about it.
-All I can say is that
this $1.9 trillion
being jammed
in a partisan fashion,
doubling the minimum wage,
and a bunch of other stuff,
is the furthest thing
from unity I have seen.
-Really?
It's the furthest thing
from unity you've seen?
Was your vision obstructed
from the Trump flag
rioters hung
at the Capitol?
So, Republicans have,
for the most part,
pledged complete and total
loyalty to Trump
as he prepares to reemerge
for his first
post-presidency speech.
Not only that,
Trump's lies about the election
have essentially become canon
on the right.
Over the weekend,
House GOP whip Steve Scalise
refused to say that the election
wasn't stolen.
And earlier this week, the
chairman of CPAC, Matt Schlapp,
of the law firm Schlemiel
Schlimazel and Schlapp,
essentially doubled down
on the lie.
-It's still very important
that we go back
to the idea
of legal voting,
and people should be
legally registered to vote
in order to vote.
When voter fraud occurs,
no matter who...
-No, but you need
to have proof.
-...it should be
fully prosecuted.
-You have to have proof that it
would have changed the outcome.
-We have it.
-You don't have it.
Matt, why do you ignore
that dozens of lawsuits
failed on this?
-Why ignore it?
-You're right.
They did --
They did fail.
But guess what -- you know this,
you're a good lawyer --
just because
you fail in court
doesn't mean you don't have
a good case.
It means you lost
in court.
-Believe it or not,
it can be both.
You can lose in court
and have a bad case --
especially if you lose 60 times,
and your lawyer
starts leaking
from the head
like he mixed up the shampoo
and the motor oil.
[As Giuliani] "Crap! No wonder
my car wouldn't start!
Oh, Rudy, this is
while your cousin left you."
[Normal voice]
And yet, as crazy as these
people are, there's no doubt
that they are
the core constituency
in the modern
Republican party --
a party that has become
totally unmoored from reality,
that relishes performative
cruelty, and traffics in racism,
cultural grievances,
and paranoia.
Even the few
non-psychotic Republicans left
are willing
to admit this.
Utah Senator Mitt Romney
said this week that,
if Trump runs
in 2024,
he'll probably win
the nomination.
-Will President Trump continue
to play a role in my party?
I'm sure he will.
He has, by far,
the largest voice,
and a big impact
in my party.
I don't know if he'll run
in 2024 or not,
but if he does, I'm pretty sure
he will win the nomination.
-You think he would
win the nomination?
-Oh, I think he'd win
the nomination if he runs.
The polls show that, among
the names being floated
as potential contenders
in 2024,
if you put President Trump
in there, among Republicans,
he wins in a landslide.
And I would probably be
getting behind somebody
who I thought more represented
the tiny wing
of the Republican party
that I represent.
-So leave the party.
The distance between you
and Joe Biden is nothing
compared to the gulf
between you and Donald Trump.
You don't have to go down with
the ship like that old couple
that stayed in bed
in "Titanic."
But he's right
on both counts.
Trump would probably
win the nomination,
and the wing of the party
that Romney represents is tiny.
There aren't many Romney stans
left in the GOP.
Even when he was the nominee
in 2012, Republican voters
backed him with all
the enthusiasm of a teen
who asked their parents for BTS
tickets and got Kenny G instead.
"Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought you love it, since,
you know, you play the saxophone
in marching band.
I mean, look how close
you are to the stage.
No good deed, I guess."
This is the modern GOP --
a party fully detached
from reality,
and from the mainstream
of American politics.
They're in lockstep
behind an ex-president
who fomented
a violent insurrection,
and who oversaw a reign
of misery and mass death.
But they're calling
a COVID relief bill
that has 76% support from voters
"divisive."
If you think that's divisive,
can you imagine
what he thinks about the return
of the Sea Captain?
-Oh, my God, I hate it.
-Okay.
I know we're hard on you,
Lindsey, but Jesus.
This has been
"A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.